GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYBODY AND WE
ARE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GET
STARTED AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
WE DO HAVE.
.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN HERE TO
PRESENT EIGHT THE TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY GOOD AFTERNOON IS A GOOD
AFTERNOON. COMMITTEE MADAM
CHAIR.
SIRS.
BAMS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO PRESENT ON
AB TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY IT'S A
BILL SPONSORED BY THAT MILITARY
DEPARTMENT TO ALLOW THE UPON
DIRECT APPOINT A FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE MILITARY
RESERVE.
TO FULL TIME ACTIVITY FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL TO SERVE AS A YOUTH.
CHALLENGE PROGRAM COUNCIL.
AS YOU KNOW WE HAVE.
OUR SECOND.
WE HAVE TO YOUTH CHALLENGE
PROGRAM IN THE STATE OUR THIRD
WAS OPENED.
YEAR AND A HALF AGO WE ARE
GRADUATING GETTING READY
GRADUATE OUR THIRD CLASS WERE
VERY EXCITED.
BUT ONE OF THE ISSUES IS BEING
ABLE TO HIRE ENOUGH FOLKS TO
COME IN FOR SUPPORT.
.
THE SOCIAL WORKER AB DID THIS
SOCIAL ENCOUNTERS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT ROLES.
THEY'VE HAD A POSITION TO
ADVERTISE FOR EIGHTEEN MONTHS
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO HIRE ANYBODY
YET.
SO WE ARE HOPING TO MAKE THIS
PROCESS A LITTLE BIT EASIER TO
BE ABLE ELECT THEM DIRECTLY
HIGHER OVER FROM.
.
THE RESERVE TO FULL TIME ACTIVE
DUTY.
WIRELESS HIGHWAY MICHELLE
O'BRIEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT AND.
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL.
TO THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR
CARRYING THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
THE. THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT AND
WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
RIGHT.
.
DO WE HAVE AND IT ARE YOU ALL
FINISHED.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
TESTIMONIES FOR.
YOU NEED TO MORE.
THAT'S MONEY IN OPPOSITION.
TO HAVE QUESTIONS FROM THE
PANEL.
WE DO NOT KNOW RIGHT WE ARE OKAY
WE HAD A OF THE MOTION WAS.
.
AND THE SECOND WAS.
ROCKY ROCKY ATTENTION
RIGHT AND WE WILL BE ABLE TO
TAKE A OF.
VOTE YET BECAUSE WE ARE WAITING
FOR A QUORUM BUT SAYS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE WILL TAKE THIS
UP AS SOON AS WE. HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
RIGHT NO THANK YOU DEGREE
PROGRAM YOU'VE GOT ONE DOWN BY
BY YOUR AREA TO.
YEAH YEAH REALLY EXCITING REALLY
EXCITING YEAH THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN.
ALRIGHT.
ALRIGHT WE'RE GETTING CLOSER.
.
IS ON THE CONCERT FROM.
ABSOLUTELY.
THERE'S A MONDAY.
GROWING THREE CAN.
STEVEN WAS IN THOSE.
THE IMAGE.
A.
SOMEONE.
ALRIGHT SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
CAN I HAVE THE.
.
TERRY PLEASE.
TAKE FOR ALL.
IRWIN HERE.
VOEPEL.
CHAVEZ THEY'RE DAILY VERY.
FRAZIER.
GLORIA. MATHIS.
MURATSUCHI. QUIRK SILVA.
SOLACE.
RIGHT AND THAT WE'RE GONNA TAKE
A VOTE RIGHT NOW ON A. B..
TWENTY EIGHT SEVENTY AG AND THE.
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS WITH
A MOTION BY FRAZIER INSECT BY
CHAVEZ.
IRWIN AYE IRWIN AYE VOEPEL.
CHAVEZ CHáVEZ AYE DEALING.
DALY AYE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MURATSUCHI. QUIRK SILVA.
SOLACE. FOLLOWS I.
SIX ZERO.
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT AND WE
HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA HERE
TWO PERCENT. A. B. FOR THIRTY
NINE GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AND I
PRESENT TO YOU E. B. TWO FOUR
THREE NINE. LGBT VETERANS
MEMORIAL.
THIS IS A BILL THAT WAS
PRESENTED TO US BY THE CITY
PEPITO CITY THE AM VETS POST
SIXTY SIX WHICH IS. RESPONSIBLE
FOR ERECTING A MONUMENT AT THE
DOES ARE MORE PARK.
IN CATHEDRAL CITY CALIFORNIA IN
ORDER TO HONOR LGBT VETS MAKING
THE MEMORIAL THE FIRST OF ITS
KIND IN THE UNITED STATES.
AT THAT TIME IT WAS ACTUALLY
RECOGNIZED.
AS THE FIRST.
BY PRESIDENTS TO JOE FORD WHO
CALLED THAT WHICH I VALLEY HOME.
THAN BILL CLINTON.
PRESIDENT. GEORGE W. BUSH AND
THEN OUR.
.
PREVIOUS PRESIDENT UP ROCK OBAMA
ALL RECOGNIZING. WHAT IMPORTANT
AND MOMENTOUS OPPORTUNITY THIS
WAS TO RECOGNIZE ALL VETERANS?
IN THE UNITED STATES AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY NINE WOULD MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE FIRST STATE IN
THE UNION TO HAVE AN OFFICIAL
STATE LGBT VETERANS. MEMORIAL
CALIFORNIA.
MUST HONOR ALL VETERANS AND MEN
AND WOMEN WHO HAVE SERVED IN OUR
NATION'S ARMED FORCES. AND
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS BEFORE
YOU RESPECT WE ASK FOR A AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND IS THERE
ANY OTHER TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
AND THE TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
DR MOTION A MOVE. BACK.
SO IF MOTION BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALY A SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRAZIER.
OH TO I'M SORRY DO WE HAVE THAT
QUESTIONS FOR.
GARCIA.
NO QUESTIONS WE HAVE A.
VOCAL PLEASE. NO MOTION IS DUE
PASSED IRWIN AYE IRWIN AYE
VOEPEL.
CHáVEZ. CHáVEZ AYE DALY.
DALY AYE FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MURATSUCHI.
QUIRK SILVA.
SO WITH.
SOLIS AYE SIX ZERO.
AT BILL IT'S OUT CONGRATULATIONS
YOU ARE MUCH BETTER CHAIR
BECAUSE.
ALRIGHT AND WE ARE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR OF ONE BILL AB NINETEEN
AWAITS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS IRWIN AYE
IRWIN AYE VOEPEL.
CHAVEZ CHáVEZ I DALY. DALY AYE
FRAZIER FRAZIER AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA AYE MATHIS.
MURATSUCHI. QUIRK SILVA. SALAS
WHAT.
SOLIS.
TELL US AYE.
SIX ZERO OKAY SO I CONSENT IS
PASSED AND WE ARE GOING TO LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR TEN MINUTES I
THINK EVERYBODY FORGETTING HERE
PROMPTLY THANK YOU.
YEAH.
OVER.
IN ADDITION LARA NDADAYE'S.
YEAH.
HERE BECAUSE
.
JW BUT.
AND
.
BUT RIGHT CAN WE GIVE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AS
THE CHANCE
VOTE.
PLEASE GEAR AB NINETEEN OH EIGHT
MURATSUCHI MERCY XII.
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY NINE MERCY
CHI MURATSUCHI AYE.
AB TWENTY SEVENTY MERCY CHIA
PURSUE GI.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MASSACHUSETTS.
WAIT A MINUTE MORE WHERE.
JERRY.
YEAH.
HE I AM ACTUALLY HERE.
NO.
CHIEF EDITOR.
YEAH.
FAIR.
LIVE.
SARAJEVANS.
PLEASE.
IT IS REALLY GOING TO TELL YOU.
ZERO.
GOOD ACTORS.
MISTER VOEPEL YOU HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE NOW WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND GO THROUGH THE
BILL'S.
YOU TO BE CAREFUL IN THE.
VANNATTER.
YOU CAN TURN ON THAT LIKELY.
IF YOU NINETEEN KNOW A RUSHES TO
PASS VOEPEL.
THAT IT THE CHáVEZ BILL AB
NINETEEN KNOW A YES.
NOBEL YES.
AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY NINE
GARCIA MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
AFFIRMATIVE.
VOEPEL AFFIRMATIVE.
AB TWENTY EIGHTH SEVENTEEN.
VOEPEL.
YES VOEPEL YES.
IN EIGHT ZERO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL AND I
BELIEVE THAT IS THE END OF OUR
MEETING.
ARE